[Música]
alguna vez predijeron algo que les iba a
ocurrir en sus vidas y no les pasó
yo hace muchos años cuando la chica
pensaba estaba re segura que me iba a
dedicar a la actuación y estoy acá en un
escenario pero soy politóloga y cuando
yo fui a la facultad a mí me enseñaron
que en algún momento el capitalismo se
iba auto destruir por su propia fuerza y
no paso y también me contaron que más o
menos para esta época íbamos a estar en
el fin de las ideologías creo que
tampoco hasta un hecho tan importante
para la historia como la caída del muro
de berlín no pudo ser anticipado
que las predicciones en la política y en
las vidas a veces la pifia
hace muchos años cuando nos imaginábamos
que la tecnología iba a transformar
radicalmente a la política se decía que
el voto y por internet iba a ser
universal en 2030 parecía que los
cambios en la forma de gobernar nos iban
a venir por ahí
es más cuando yo tuve que decidir mi
tema de tesis de doctorado decidí
estudiar el voto electrónico era un tema
de tesis raro porque la ciencia política
siempre se ocupa del presente o del
pasado reciente pero a mí lo que me
desvelaba del futuro de la política era
eso era como el voto electrónico lo iba
a ser o eso creía en ese momento se
decía hay muchos proyectaban que íbamos
a votar en 2030 en pijamas desde
nuestras casas y que el voto electrónico
con unas máquinas parecidas a los
cajeros automáticos como ésta iba a ser
la antesala del voto por internet y yo
la miro y pienso que muy probablemente
esta predicción también la va a pifiar
porque ya hoy en 2019 cada vez hay menos
países que usan voto electrónico
la política está cambiando sí pero no de
la forma en que imaginábamos yo sigo
convencida que entender el futuro de la
política es clave y junto a varios
colegas argentinos y de otros países
estamos tratando de entender cómo va a
ser el 2030 cómo nos vamos a gobernar
déjeme contarles algunas cosas que
tenemos alguna certeza de cómo va a ser
en 2030
y seguro a una transforma de la política
en 2030 la inteligencia artificial
aplicada a los procesos de todo tipo de
producción de servicios va haber
transformado las economías desarrolladas
y muy probablemente va a haber agrandado
la brecha la distancia con los países en
desarrollo como la argentina si no se
adaptan a los cambios que vienen
también sabemos y lo vemos venir
lamentablemente que vamos a estar
sufriendo los efectos del calentamiento
global y muy probablemente para 2030 el
centro del poder económico mundial va a
haber girado hacia
china probablemente va haber reemplazado
a eeuu como el centro del mundo
económico y europa va a ser una región
menos poderosa
pocos ponen en duda estas mega
tendencias y eso quiere decir que el
motor de cambio no va a ser solamente la
tecnología que siempre acapara la
atención
y es cierto porque la cuarta revolución
industrial como le llaman algunos seguro
va a cambiar la forma de gestionar no sé
tendremos asesores políticos que sean
robots también seguro va a cambiar la
forma en que nos relacionamos con
nuestros representantes y ya lo estamos
viendo y nos sorprende por ejemplo
cuando el presidente de trump comunica a
su política exterior así en un tuit
y eso nos trae problemas que antes no
teníamos porque la legislación de eeuu
no pide que guardemos estos tuits pero
si nos pide que guardemos los discursos
de trump cuando va el congreso
y también hay cambios que nos preocupan
porque están llegando antes que nos
podemos ocupar de ellos piensen por
ejemplo cómo están cambiando las
campañas electorales y hoy nuestras
leyes se volvieron obsoletas regulan
cuánto se gasta en la televisión cuánto
se gasta en la radio pero no dicen nada
de cómo se usa facebook o whatsapp para
informar o para desinformar a los
votantes pero la transformación más
profunda de la política no bastará en la
tecnología
el cambio a pasar por quienes van a
tomar decisiones en un mundo tan
distinto y sobre qué asuntos las vamos a
poder tomar
para imaginarnos cómo se va a gobernar
el 2030 tenemos que pensar cómo van a
ser dos de sus protagonistas centrales
los gobiernos y las empresas y ahí les
tengo que decir que tenemos más
incógnitas que certezas
donde se van a tomar las decisiones
serán las ciudades en las naciones que
cada vez están más encerradas sobre sus
fronteras o serán las instituciones
globales en las que creamos después de
la segunda guerra como las naciones
unidas o las que vayamos a crear
hoy los nacionalismos están en auge y
cada vez más hay desconfianza en esas
instituciones globales que creamos es
más lo vemos por ejemplo en el break
city los líderes políticos cada vez
privilegia más las identidades locales
pero también estamos viendo que los
problemas son cada vez más globales y no
hay un solo país que los pueda
solucionar
piensen por ejemplo en cómo protegemos
la privacidad de nuestros datos en
internet hay muchas voces estoy diciendo
que esas instituciones globales tienen
que tener más fuerza tienen que tener un
rol más importante
como será entonces las decisiones más
locales o más globales
el problema es que los países hoy son
muy grandes para los problemas pequeños
pero muy pequeños para los problemas
grandes
esa es la primera incógnita la segunda
incógnita es cómo van a ser las empresas
del futuro vamos a vivir en un mundo de
pymes muy especializadas o en un mundo
de grandes empresas que ostenten mucho
del poder económico global
nos entusiasmamos con que la tecnología
iba a bajar los costos que íbamos a
tener un mercado cada vez más disperso
más descentralizado pero hoy los
gigantes la tecnología
amazon google facebook cada vez están
más concentrados no sabemos cómo van a
hacer las empresas del futuro y esa es
la segunda incógnita
si nosotros cruzamos esas dos
dimensiones
podemos pensar distintos mundos donde
vamos a vivir muy distintos cuatro
mundos para el 2030
y los invito a que nos asomemos juntos
al futuro de la política en un extremo
podríamos vivir en un mundo dominado por
grandes empresas bajo un gobierno global
no sea una especie de parlamento mundial
una nueva versión de las naciones
unidas- nosotros ese mundo lo llamamos
mi buen amigo el gigante se acuerdan
como el cuento de dalt que se llevó al
cine
en este mundo seguro podemos tener
alguna posibilidad de encontrarle una
solución al cambio climático o algún
problema global pero seguramente en este
mundo nos sintamos muy lejos de las
decisiones que se toman en los centros
de poder global quizás algún algoritmo a
ayuda que tomen en cuenta nuestras
preferencias pero sería muy distinto a
hoy
y eso sí en este mundo necesitamos unos
líderes políticos muy capaces tienen que
llevar a cabo un doble juego tienen que
negociar con las grandes empresas y
tomar decisiones que nos rigen a todos
los ciudadanos del mundo
estamos formando a esos líderes
políticos
y ahora los invito a viajar al mundo
opuesto también posible un mundo donde
hay muchas pequeñas empresas pymes muy
especializadas
con gobiernos locales
a este mundo nos gusta llamarlo lo
pequeño es hermoso pero no estoy tan
segura de que vaya a ser tan hermoso acá
la innovación tecnológica va a ser más
lenta
y no va a ser posible seguramente que le
encontremos alguna solución al cambio
climático va a ser muy difícil coordinar
las acciones entre tantos actores
eso sí seguramente nos sintamos más
partícipe de las decisiones
y hay otros dos mundos posibles más un
mundo de unos pocos pies grandes del
sector privado conviven con muchos
gobiernos más pequeños no sé quizás de
es una familiar en este mundo las
grandes empresas que operan más allá de
límites territoriales resisten las
decisiones de los gobiernos más pequeños
y hay un cuarto mundo también posible
quizás el menos probable en el cual
vivimos en un ecosistema de pequeñas
empresas que compiten bajo una autoridad
global
en cada uno de estos cuatro mundos las
decisiones se van a tomar de manera muy
distinta y seguramente tenga un impacto
muy distinto en la democracia que hoy
está siendo cuestionada en muchos lados
y muy distintos italia-brasil la india
es que las frustraciones con la política
provocan mucha bronca con las
dirigencias y hoy aparecen fenómenos
nuevos
quizás lo vieron hace unas semanas en
ucrania un cómico que actúa de
presidente en la serie se convirtió en
presidente lo eligieron de presidente de
verdad en las urnas que a veces la
política supera la ficción
cualquier análisis que hagamos cualquier
combinación de estos escenarios
seguramente va a darnos un mundo
distinto
y no sabremos muchas preguntas queremos
un parlamento mundial que se ocupe de
por ejemplo regular la inteligencia
artificial
creemos que puede convivir un parlamento
mundial con gobiernos más pequeños que
se ocupen de los problemas más chicos
más locales
hay un sistema distinto a la democracia
que vayamos a inventar va a ser el
régimen más extendido del mundo o el
giro hacia ahora que tengamos más
autoritarismos o crearemos una nueva
forma de gobernar nos todas esas
preguntas no las hacemos porque el
futuro de la política no está escrito
aún y seguramente cuando hagamos estas
predicciones la pifiamos como con el
voto electrónico
pero trazar esos escenarios y poder
imaginarnos cuál es el que nos parecen
más deseables mejor para la argentina
es un juego es un juego divertido pero
decimos
pero también es un acto de
responsabilidad porque lo que vaya a
ocurrir allá en el 2030 va a ser mucho
que ver con lo que hagamos hoy con los
cambios que emprendamos hoy con como
formemos a los próximos dirigentes y con
cómo anticipemos los dilemas del futuro
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
e